Arthur Fleck is afflicted with an uncontrollable
urge to laugh, but it's clear he also has
a penchant for cutting a rug.
As seen in director Todd Phillips' Joker,
Joaquin Phoenix's iteration of the Clown Prince
of Crime dances quite frequently, primarily
as a means of self-expression.
A man who struggles with mental health issues,
fails at turning his love of making other
people laugh into a legitimate career, and
is often the target of attacks from strangers,
Arthur mostly keeps to himself.
But when he's alone, he's free to move his
feet and wave his arms as he pleases.
So, why all the dancing in Joker?
Phillips recently spoke about how that aspect
of Arthur's physicality came to fruition,
and why it's important in the film.
Chatting with Collider, Phillips explained
that he and Phoenix identified a certain quality
in Arthur Fleck very early on - that being
that he, quote, "had music in him," which
manifested itself through the character's
dancing.
The filmmaker elaborated:
"It just existed in him.
Some people that you might know personally
have that feeling, and I always thought that
about Arthur, but it was sort of kept in and
trapped.
And there was something about that evolving."
Phillips also revealed that a lot of the dancing
in the film wasn't planned out in the script.
Originally, the Joker script only included
Arthur performing something close to a dance
while working as a sign-spinner as seen in
the movie's opening sequence, and later shimmying
down the stairs in his clown makeup and Joker
suit.
According to Phillips, the dancing was, quote,
"something that kind of evolved" to show how
the music within Arthur was "fighting to get
out."
When it does, each dance marks an important
point along Arthur's narrative journey.
He dances when he feels good about himself
and is totally comfortable with embracing
who he is; when he brings that out into the
real world, his dancing becomes not only a
form of self-expression, but is a way for
him to reaffirm his increasingly menacing
place in the world.
"For my whole life, I didn't know if I even
really existed - but I do."
The director later admitted that he thinks
Joker should have had even more dancing, as
he absolutely loved it in the movie.
So just how did Joaquin Phoenix prepare for
all that dancing?
Well, he had a little help, of course!
Though it wouldn't take a Juilliard graduate
or a professional ballerina to execute the
dance moves Arthur Fleck did in the film,
Joker star Joaquin Phoenix still had to do
some prep work to get his character's movements
just right.
As he revealed to Collider, his dancing prep
approach was split into two parts: working
with choreographer Michael Arnold and turning
to YouTube to study people's movements.
When discussing the striking scene in which
Arthur struts down some steps, Phoenix told
Collider:
"I worked with this choreographer for that,
but then…after working with him, Michael
Arnold was his name, I just started watching
a lot of videos of people dancing, movement…"
He later shared with The Washington Post that
he was particularly inspired by Ray Bolger,
an actor, dancer, and Broadway performer popular
in the 1930s.
Specifically, Phoenix drew inspiration from
Bolger's performance of "The Old Soft Shoe"
and the, quote, "odd arrogance" he displayed
through his dancing.
Arnold had shown Phoenix that video, which
was a huge part in helping the actor perfect
Arthur's unique manner of moving.
Phoenix confessed:
"Really, I completely just stole it from [Bolger].
He does this thing of turning his chin up.
This choreographer Michael Arnold showed me
that and tons of videos and I zeroed in on
that one.
That was Joker, right?
There's an arrogance to him, really.
That was probably the greatest influence."
Another genre of dance that heavily influenced
the dancing in Joker?
Disco, though the jury's still out on whether
Phoenix ever tried to emulate John Travolta
in Saturday Night Fever while preparing for
the film's dance sequences.
If you've yet to catch Joker, bunny-hop to
your local theater to learn exactly why some
critics are calling it Oscar-worthy.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.